the moment that I was introduced to
K-pop was on Saturday Night Live in
April 2019 when the group BTS or Banton
soniandan appeared being Asian American
myself I hadn't realized how much I had
missed seeing people that look like me
um on screen on a show that I watched
since I was a kid there's a long history
of Asian American men in the media
either being just completely invisible
or being deemed is not worthy of
romantic relationships so from a
sociological point of view that itself
seemed interesting there were also
articles about how Asian Americans who
always felt like they were somehow
ashamed or felt like they weren't cool
that somehow K-pop elevated their status
my collaborator who is Korean also said
that people recognize his name as being
Korean and suddenly being Korean was
cool when I was a kid if you had an
ethnic name an Asian ethnic name people
tried really hard to change it the most
popular person on Tick Tock is a guy
named Jungkook like he didn't have to
anglicize his name and so I never
thought this would happen in my lifetime
[Music]